open the door to walk this dude out and
this other guy jumps up on this this
step puts a 45 caliber pistol right in
my face literally right here in my face
jammed the barrel right into my head you
can see the scar right here okay then he
took the back of it and started
hammering both sides of my head
underneath the mouth on top of the head
put 76 stitches in my head and face and
I went to the hospital 28 Days Later I
was in a treatment center for drug
addiction and I finally put my first
couple days not using drugs together but
more importantly than not doing
something I started something that day
I'm going to become somebody